in den vergangenen jahrzehnten hat
kaffee eine revolution erlebt für das
getränk sind viele bereit auch etwas
mehr zu bezahlen
im dezember 2009 10 fährt unser team zum
ersten mal nach guatemala innerhalb von
drei tagen besucht das team vier
kaffeeplantagen wir werden zeigen die
kinder unter schrecklichen bedingungen
auf den plantagen ausgebeutet werden die
starbucks und nespresso beliefern unsere
bilder belegen dass beide unternehmen
gegen internationales arbeitsrecht
verstoßen obwohl sie täglich viele
stunden auf den plantagen arbeiten
verdienen sie nicht einmal das was wir
für einen kaffee latte bezahlen
nespresso verspricht nachhaltigen anbau
unter korrekten arbeitsbedingungen
genau wie starbucks
trotzdem sehen wir kinder die knochen
arbeit verrichten
[Musik]
diese arbeitsbedingungen sind für kinder
gefährlich kinder sollten nicht so
arbeiten